die entdeckung einer neuen landmasse wie
bitte das kennen wir vielleicht nur von
christoph kolumbus aber tatsächlich
wurde jetzt in der antarktis eine neue
insel entdeckt ein us forschungsteam hat
diese insel dort aufgespürt die sich
bislang unter den resten von bachelors
getarnt hat es in island diese
entdeckung führt uns vor augen wie
rasant und brutal der klimawandel die
welt verändert doch vielleicht könnte
diese insel auch etwas positives
bewirken kicks um science-fiction hier
gibt's täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann und nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen es handelt sich tatsächlich
um eine extreme hitzewelle die der
südkontinent mittlerweile zum dritten
mal in diesem antarktischen sommer
erlebt vor allem auf der antarktischen
halbinsel kommt es zu extremen
temperaturen anfang februar wurde an der
argentinischen forschungsstation mahr am
bio eine temperatur von 20,75 grad
celsius gemessen und das ist ein
wirklich dramatischer und trauriger
rekord in der geschichte der
wetteraufzeichnungen in der antarktis
der anstieg der temperaturen erfolgt in
dieser region der erde in einem rasanten
tempo
nach angaben der weltwetterorganisation
wmo ist es hier im schnitt mittlerweile
drei grad wärmer als noch vor 50 jahren
die folgen sind dramatisch die
eisschilde und gletscher der antarktis
schmelzen und der meeresspiegel steigt
immer weiter 2009 10 wird das
zweitwärmste jahr seit beginn der
wetteraufzeichnung und das große
schmelzen hinterlässt seine spuren bzw
unglaubliche folgen
auf einer expedition hat einen us
forschungsteam jetzt eine bislang
unbekannte insel in der antarktis
aufgespürt das war eine riesige
überraschung für die fachleute ich
glaube ich sehe felsen hatte eine
beteiligte wissenschaftlerin gerufen als
das schiff durch die pine island b
gefahren war doch bei der durchsicht der
karten stellte sich schnell heraus dass
es sich hierbei um eine brandneue insel
handeln muss die freude über diesen fund
ließ aber schnell nach als den
forschenden klar wurde welche ursachen
dahinter stecken der klimawandel
verändert den kontinent enorm und in
rasend schnellem tempo dass uns diese
insel bislang verborgen blieb ist kein
wunder denn sie lag unter der dicken
eisschicht des 1
allen gletschers dieser 250 km lange
beinahe länder ist enorm wichtig für die
westantarktis zusammen mit seinem
nachbarn dem zweites gletscher
stabilisiert er weitere gletscher beide
bilden quasi eine art stöpsel der die
eismassen daran hindert in den ozean
dahinter zu gelangen passiert dies doch
würde der meeresspiegel nach nasa
angaben bis zu zweieinhalb meter 2,4
meter genau ansteigen und zwar selbst
dann wenn wir ab jetzt sofort alle co2
emissionen stoppen würden klar ist das
amt ein island gletscher in jedem sommer
mehr eis ins meer verloren geht als von
der landseite nachrücken kann die
fachleute tauften dass island sich
angelehnt an die frau des donnergottes
thor der nordischen mythologie die
inseln besteht dann analysen zufolge aus
abgeschliffenen granitblöcken dieser gar
nicht wurde wohl über jahrhunderte
hinweg von dem gletscher rund
geschliffen das forschungsteam namen
gesteinsproben um durch eine analyse
mehr über die geologischen prozesse
herauszufinden dazu twittert julia smith
eine der beteiligten forscherinnen after
being the first visitors wie can confirm
that if island ist made of green it and
discover the moon and eisschelf and the
future
reste von gletschereis bedecken also die
insel aus granit auf der auch einige
robben leben möglicherweise steckt der
folgende geologische prozesse hinter dem
ganzen
durch den rückgang der gletscher hat der
druck der meter dicken eispanzer auf die
erdkruste nachgelassen so dass diese
aufsteigen konnte spricht die insel war
zum teil verborgen ist aber auch durch
den fehlenden druck aufgestiegen dieser
prozess könnte nach ansicht der
fachleute wiederum zu einem schnellen
abbruch von eis an dem
antarktisgletscher führen auf der
anderen seite könnte solch eine
aufgestiegene insel die eismassen aber
auch stabilisieren und als barriere
daran hindern ins offene meer
abzudriften weitere analysen und
untersuchungen sind dringend notwendig
um die prozesse an solchen gletschern
endlich besser zu verstehen denn die
veränderungen in der antarktis gehen uns
alle an manche forschenden befürchten
sogar dass schlimmste nämlich dass der
kipp punkt bereits erreichtes demnach
könnte der klimawandel bereits jetzt
schon dafür gesorgt haben dass das
abtauen der riesigen gletscher der
amundsen see unumkehrbar ist langfristig
könnten dann auch große metropolen wie
shanghai
new york genauso wie hamburg und bremen
unter wasser stehen klimaforscher irren
sich
takko gletscher in alaska schmilzt 80
jahre zu früh anklicken anschauen und
klicks manager unbedingt abonnieren wenn
es noch nicht getan haben soll sind
einer der ganz wenigen kanal auf youtube
die sich ausschließlich um umwelt und
natur kümmern also bis dann bleibt dran
und zwar auch bei pixum nature